oh big game and alley it is good to be
back and look at that set of bigs right
there we got a.d
dwight
deandre jordan
oh that's looking nice
oh and there's dwight yelling
and 80s laughing and deandre's
pretending to yell
and i got i got good news for everybody
a.d
is on the way he's here he's got the
headset on
newlywed
packers are actually playing some some
good football all of a sudden a.d it's
good to be you right now isn't it
laker season's bag has been it's been a
great week oh then there's that two
weeks
yeah the lakers are starting too thanks
alex
thanks for thanks for doing the job
right
can i start this off first before we get
into basketball please yes please
again congratulations to you on getting
married that is amazing that's awesome
but i want to know what's more
accomplishing for you
getting the game winner versus denver in
the western conference finals or
nailing your performance to your now
wife oh
i know this answer let's say
yes you know
[Laughter]
listen i uh i had a great time it was
fun i think the performance of my wife
was uh was definitely the better the
better performers uh it was it was a had
a blast we had a great time
i don't know if you know this a.d big
game can sing as well big game you rate
him pretty high
it take takes guts big games yeah i mean
you know you you you got the pipes
nice little nice little baritone
different octaves
uh cool everybody trying to go on tour
you know what we can do a little duo at
some point i know you have other things
to focus on but yeah cool under pressure
and passion
you got you got a little marvin gaye in
your brother i'm telling you i love that
we're three minutes in allie i love that
we're three minutes in we haven't even
thought about a basketball question
wife happy life happy wife now we can
get to the box go ahead al you go first
um you know a.d when you finished season
um
after obviously that first round exit i
have been very excited to talk to you
because you were excited about getting
back to your off season routine
what did that look like what was the day
in the life this summer in terms of
hoops for anthony davis
yeah um
just getting my body right you know i
was very disappointed
uh and i first went on exit more so
myself just because of all the injuries
i can't blame any anyone else i mean we
we can say the short offseason
um and it kind of did have an effect
on a lot of guys bodies around the
league but for me i just want to get
back to my
12 to 14 16 week all season training
that i'm accustomed to to get my body
prepared for
a season you know and i was able to do
that this summer
i feel great
body is healthy
i'm excited to go to go back out and
show the world
you know what i've been doing and you
know i've been keeping it under wraps i
had no cameras i don't do the cameras
and stuff anyway doing workouts but only
if you're singing
only if i'm singing that's it
but i uh you know i i i try to you know
keep it under wraps and just try to keep
my head down and just work this summer
yeah i love that about you and uh
whether it's listen adi whether it's
reports or talk around nba or lakers
when it comes to you it's always about
playing more center it's really a topic
i think that's probably talked about too
much that being said does that make it
is there a different mindset or did it
change the way you prepared for this
offseason
uh no
to be honest it was kind of the same way
but as far as you know the center thing
um
i have no problem with it being frank
had numerous conversations about it uh
me lb and russ had conversations about
it
and they really want to get my opinion
on how i felt about it and i'm cool with
it i think it helps our team um now
obviously there's gonna be games and
where you know dj and dwight i'll start
at center but
uh i think the plan now is to you know
start me at center or maybe start them
and come out i'm not sure
how frank really got to set but
i know i will be playing center a lot
more than i did last year yeah i i think
wherever you play it's it's going to be
it's going to be beneficial for the team
i i i'm old school i like inside out
first and then you can do whatever you
want but i wanted to talk to you a
little bit about your off-season workout
because i know in my career it took me
two or three years to realize that the
stronger my body is you know the more i
could withstand the more i could you
know
take on injuries and things of that
nature
how how have you felt about that at this
point of your career given the fact that
you do take a lot of punishment night in
and night out the way teams play you
physically and and how that has worked
out for you in the off season
yeah so my first year here i had a great
offseason and um
i forgot i played i think about like 72
games or something like that um and a
couple of them was just because of you
know rest
um you know the whole entire playoffs
didn't miss a game and
like i said last year was kind of a
season that i want to put behind me
because of all injuries and the amount
of time that i missed
not being able to help my team on on the
floor
and not from the sideline so
it's a huge part it's a huge part in you
know what you know us athletes go
through
and i realize same thing you realize
that
the stronger your body is and
the more you train your body and off
season and also maintaining during the
season you can withstand those those
injuries
because you never know how you're going
to fall or
the
position that you that you have to move
in
but if you train in
various positions and
able to
lift a lot of weights and and you know
strengthen the muscles
and ligaments in your body then you have
a high percentage chance of withstanding
those you know my new injuries or the
bigger injuries that
some people have gotten in the past
season
so i i feel great like i said i've been
you know training
my butt off
to make sure that i'm i'm available to
my team whenever they need me
anthony we know uh the end goal for all
of you is bringing banner number 18 to
the franchise getting back to the top
um but we know it also starts with the
three of you you lebron and ross it's
one thing to talk about it it's another
to actually be about it
um based off the conversations that you
guys have had what you know of the game
the fit what gives you the confidence
that the three of you can lead this team
to where it ultimately wants to be
uh one word sacrifice
we all players who sacrifice for the
better betterment of the team
and uh
you know before russ
got here and
right after russ got traded here we
talked about that
the only way this is going to work is if
we all sacrifice
and we are willing to do that obviously
you know me and brian have done it
um
and now bringing russell who wants to
win and he's very very unselfish
we all want to to make sure that
you know we want the best for each other
and for our team and you know it starts
with us three and i think by us being
selfless players that we're going to be
able to make this work we're going to
make everyone better we're going to make
each other better
and you know as long as we you know have
one common goal in mind throughout the
entire season that you know it's all
about banner number 18 about and about
nothing else then i think we should be
in a good position to to reach that goal
a.d we appreciate your time and uh we
can't wait to get this thing cracking
and uh talking to you at practices and
games man it's time to get it back going
right
yeah thank you thank you guys all right
anthony thank you
all right thanks a.d thank you
gotta let him go got him to go busy day
for i don't like when they tell us that
i know i want to keep going i want to
keep going um
it is a big topic
him playing center it's always talked
about i'm sure he asks he gets asked
that question a lot did you like his
answer big game james i think that i
think that's what laker fans wanted to
hear yeah and i i liked his answer and
and i respect his answers in the past
you know based on his success and how he
plays the game but there comes a time
where he said sacrifice
and
i'm telling you him being in the post
especially early in the game the
defenses are going to collapse i promise
you or else he's going to have a field
day and i think that's the sacrifice
that he has to make in order for the
perimeter shooters to get comfortable
shots maybe some uncontested shots uh
you know cuts through the lanes it's
just going to benefit the entire offense
so i like the fact that he's willing to
you know go down in the post get mean
and nasty go quick when he gets the ball
create other opportunities for his
teammates